NARRATOR: Baalbek, Lebanon,
the 9,000-year-old Temple
of Jupiter contains three of
the largest monolithic stones
in the world, weighing
approximately 1,000 tons,
or two million pounds each.
Pumapunku, Bolivia, scattered
across a high desert plateau
are precisely-cut,
100 ton blocks,
believed to date back
at least 2,000 years,
and perhaps much earlier.
The Giza Plateau, Egypt.
The Great Pyramid is
built from more than 2.3
million limestone
bricks, each weighing
a staggering 5,000 pounds.
All around the world
stand colossal monuments
to mankind's ancient past,
gigantic structures that
have endured for thousands of
years, built with stone blocks
so massive, that modern
builders have not even
attempted to duplicate them.
[machinery whirring]
Our 988 Cat loader can
probably lift a 22 ton
boulder, just for perspective.
And it can probably roll
and drag along the ground
maybe a 40 ton boulder.
But when you're talking
a 50 ton boulder,
then we need to bring in cranes,
hydraulic jacks, steel beams,
girders.
It's a whole nother
set of tools, even
with modern day technology.
I mean, I can only
imagine how they
would move boulders that size.
It baffles my mind.
I have no idea.
It's crazy to think about.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: How is it
possible that 10,000
years ago, our ancestors
moved around the most
massive of stones?
The answer is either another
previous super civilization
existed here on Earth, or
extraterrestrials imparting
technological knowledge to us.
Ancient astronaut theorists
suggest such structures provide
physical evidence that
extraterrestrial beings
visited Earth and assisted our
ancestors in the distant past.
And each of these three
megalithic sites--
as well as numerous others--
have very specific
stories behind them that
say they were built not by men.
But by the gods using
the power of levitation.
GIORGIO: Some ancient
mythologies speak of the fact
that some of these stones were
put into place with sound,
that these things all of a
sudden levitated into place.
What the local legend of
Stonehenge talks about
is that those big
stones were transported
by way of levitation.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: Similar to the
mythical story of Stonehenge,
the ancient legends
of Bolivia say
that the megalithic
stones of Pumapunku
were floated into place.
In the 5th century BC, the
Greek historian Herodotus
wrote that the Egyptians
were given knowledge
from the guardians of
the sky on how to float
the massive limestone
blocks with which
they built the Great Pyramid.
What we see is the
very real possibility
that extraterrestrial
civilizations visited Earth
all throughout the world,
and that each time they did,
they felt it was very important
to impart this sacred knowledge
about the importance of acoustic
frequencies and the keys
to unlocking the
mysteries of the universe.
NARRATOR: The
University of Bristol,
England, January 17, 2017.
Researchers unveil a
prototype for what they call
a portable tractor
beam, a handheld device
that can levitate small
objects using only sound waves.
[music playing]
Recently, the
University of Bristol
came up with a handheld device
with an array of speakers that
allows the holder of this to
actually focus sound waves
and sound waves alone,
and then levitate
small pieces of light material.
When we look at this
portable tractor beam,
can we extrapolate the idea
that this is a technology
in its infancy, where
in ancient times,
it was actually being used
to levitate large stones.